who is it welcome right
check one two three
oh
here we go all right i'm gonna party
baby
so
okay
anyways
oh
it's a good one
um
okay
almost like done
man
thank you
is
so
uh
uh
nice
so
all right
all right no no okay
oh
yes
i'm headed this way
beautiful beautiful
it's the only good picture
easy
oh
okay
okay
thank you
perfect
testing one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten two three four five
thank you
is
hello
um
humanity
um
[Music]
good morning everyone by any objective
standard the violence
chaos and anarchy in portland is
unacceptable
yet democrats continue to put politics
above peace while this president seeks
to restore
law and order governor kate brown a
democrat governor of oregon said that
the president should quote stop playing
politics called law enforcement officers
secret police and likened it to
quote a dictatorship the governor also
called on the president to get his
officers
off the streets democrat mayor of
portland todd wheeler said the president
is trying to look strong for his base
while
you had democrats on the hill nancy
pelosi
calling these officers storm troopers
and jim clyburn calling them
the gestapo this rhetoric is unhelpful
and gives the violence we have seen a
pass but president trump will not give
the violence a pass
he will restore order where the democrat
governor and the democrat
mayor are unwilling to admit that they
have lost control
of their city the well-organized mob in
portland has become increasingly
aggressive especially
against law enforcement officers
individuals have thrown bricks
chunks of concrete glass bottles feces
balloons filled with paint pig's feet
slingshots to hurl ball bearings
and batteries at federal agents and the
courthouse
multiple attempts to barricade officers
in the hatfield court
house have occurred attempts to start
the structure on fire as well
use of eyesight damaging laser devices
have been used
in strobe lights against federal agents
as well
but according to speaker pelosi when
asked about the
violent removal of statute statues
people will do what they do
the trump administration urges state and
local officials to work cooperatively to
restore
law and order operation legend is a
great example of this
at the governor's request we went into
kansas city and surged the area with
federal assets
fbi dea atf and us marshals
this was named after legend talafero a
four-year-old
young boy who lost his life and was shot
in his bed tragically
this has been a successful operation
that has been
waged in his name including the arrest
of wanted fugitives
similarly president trump is taking
action important
portland even though you have a democrat
mayor and democrat governor unwilling to
work with us in this situation
we are surging resources along with
secretary wolf at dhs
and augmenting the federal protective
service to safeguard federal property
the bottom line is that this president
stands with law and order
which leads to peace and we will not
allow portland to become the new chop
like what we saw in seattle and with
that i'll take questions
john kelly two questions on portland one
uh the case of navy veteran christopher
david who went down because he said he
wanted
to talk to the law enforcement officers
and ask them about the oath of office
that they took uh he was as people saw
on videotape
he was beaten with a baton he had
pepper spray sprayed in his face he now
has two broken bones in his hand
is the president of where what happened
to uh
to this navy veteran graduate of the
naval academy
and does he condone that kind of action
by these law enforcement officers yeah
i'm aware of the details of that
situation haven't heard the audio of the
video though i've seen it and i refer
you to dhs
about the extenuating details we always
encourage the appropriate
use of force and we always also
encourage those in the area to
remain peaceful towards our law
enforcement officers and my second
question is where
in the constitution does the president
derive
the authority to send federal law
enforcement officers to the streets of
american cities
against the will of the elected
officials
in those cities yes well what you're
referring to is portland and 40 u.s
code 1315 gives dhs the ability to
deputize officers in any department or
agency
like ice custom and border patrol and
secret service quote as
officers and agents they can be
deputized for the duty
of in connection with the protection of
property owned or occupied by the
federal government and persons on that
property and when a federal courthouse
is being
lit on fire commercial fireworks being
shot at it being shot at the officers
i think that that falls pretty well
within uh the limits of 40 us code 1350.
that's a matter of protecting federal
property like federal courthouse in the
case of
portland does he see limitations to that
power
how how much how far does that power
extend into the into the streets of the
city of portland how
you know what are their limitations on
that so i had that
authority to protect a federal property
under the law we believe that agents can
conduct
investigations of crimes committed
against federal property or federal
officers and in the case where you have
someone shooting off a commercial-grade
firework
and then running across the street we
don't believe that that extends past our
jurisdiction
yeah really thank you yesterday the
president tweeted out an image of
himself
wearing a mask he said that wearing a
mask is an act of patriotism no one is
more
patriotic than him then just hours later
he was spotted at the trump hotel
not wearing a mask why did it take him
so
long first of all to be seen wearing a
mask in public and why the mixed
messaging
on this critical health issue that his
own top health officials have said
is critical to fighting this pandemic
the president's always been consistent
on this that
mask according to the cdc are
recommended but not required
he has said that he would wear one in
the case he couldn't appropriately
socially distance
and then he wore one and put up the
picture on twitter as you saw
does he think that it's important to
lead by example on this issue well the
president has led he's been consistent
even going back to march 31st
when he said then my feeling is if
people want to do it there's certainly
no harm to it he hasn't done it haley he
hasn't warned him
so it's sending is it not mixed signals
the president wore a mask in may the
president wore a mask at walter reed out
of an abundance of caution but as i've
made clear from this podium the
president
is the most tested man in america he's
tested more than anyone multiple times a
day
and we believe that he's acting
appropriately let me ask you about the
federal students if i might negotiations
are ongoing why is the white house
blocking a republican
request for more funding for testing and
contact chasing
senator roy blunt saying it just doesn't
make sense i think that's just wrong
so no one is blocking any money from
testing um
one of the things i would add is that
this is an ongoing negotiation we're
just in the early days of that
i'm currently in federal coffers we have
10 billion dollars that's with a b
unspent uh that is allocated for testing
and we want to ensure that in phase four
there is money that is targeted for
testing and the way that makes most
sense
we need that money is is the president
willing to
come we're willing to put in money for
targeted testing that makes sense
not just dumping money into a pot that
already already contains 10 billion
dollars
there's very little support in congress
for a payroll tax cut but the president
keeps pushing for it
why is that so important to him how does
a payroll tax cut help
the 25 million americans out of work
when they're not getting a paycheck
well there are a number of things we're
looking at for phase four one of those
things
is unemployment benefits where as
secretary mnuchin said we want this to
be completed before
july 31st uh the date that that runs out
we don't want something to be an
incentive where
someone gets overpaid and has a
disincentive from going back to work
where they get paid more
on unemployment benefits than at work so
we want to be cautious about that while
making sure that those unemployed
are taken care of but the payroll tax in
particular goes to some of our hardest
working americans the people that it
benefits if you look at the tax
structure
are middle-income and low-income workers
and not only that there's an incentive
on the employer side with a payroll tax
holiday
that encourages them to hire more too
because it reduces their burden so it's
a very smart policy those are people who
still have
jobs so wouldn't it be more important to
focus on the people who don't if you're
worried about the overall
cost of this stimulus we can focus on a
number of things at once and
part of that's a payroll tax for middle
and income low-income americans who are
out there working each and every day and
making their way through as best they
can it also means unemployment
benefits it also means direct payments
to americans so we're looking at
all of that and we would like to see all
of that the second question on the
briefing today at five o'clock should we
expect to see members of the coronavirus
task force will dr fauci will dr burke's
be there
you'll have to tune in to see yeah thank
you um
on portland i'm sending agents to
portland as well as
plans for chicago why are these the
right people
to send my understanding these agents
often work on
uh human smuggling drug trafficking uh
things like that do they
have the right skill set whether it's
gun violence in chicago
or squelling um unrest
uh in portland well first let me add um
they haven't been sent to chicago these
dhs
officials are currently in portland
portland protecting a courthouse
we do believe they're the right
individuals for that as does 40 usc 1315
the united states code
it's egregious what's happening the
frequency jammers the paladin air rifles
in portland it's being depicted as this
peaceful scene i can assure you
it's anything but that where you've had
barricades trying to keep officers in
the
heart field hatfield excuse me
courthouse um injury to a border patrol
team member's leg injuries to the head
shoulder and back of a deputy u.s
marshal
u.s marshal impaled his right hand on a
board filled with nails set out by the
protesters
this is not a peaceful scene i'm very
thankful to our us marshals
and atf and others who are acting in
accordance with a statute and protecting
a federal building
um and doing so a great cost to
themselves
thanks really i have two questions for
you on the stimulus first
since you guys are committed to the
payroll tax cut that seems to be driving
up
the price tag of the whole package so is
the white house
view the one trillion dollar figure
that's been cited by gop leaders as a
hard cap are you willing to sign
something
that would spread more than that these
are all preliminary discussions so you
know i'll leave it to the negotiators to
decide the
uh trillion dollar number was cited by
secretary mnuchin yesterday
but look this is the beginning stages
we're looking at a number of things but
the president
was very clear that he would like to see
a payroll tax in there along with
liability protections
um tax credits for businesses to bring
people back to work and to have safe
work environments and of course
70 billion dollars for schools to reopen
safely at least 70 billion and then on
the testing
piece the one of the wait time the long
wait times that we're seeing for tests
around the country suggest that
we do need a massive influx of testing
beyond what's unspent
and that the federal government should
take more control of the federal of the
country's testing program
so we do want to see more testing
funding but we want it to be targeted in
a way that
it gets to the the right people who need
testing at the right time not just
dumping money into a bucket so we want
more money we want it to be targeted
but i'm glad you brought up the timing
of the testing i talked to dr burks and
she's very encouraged by
the pool testing that's being worked on
uh you can run
four to five times as many tests in the
same period of time
it by decreasing turnaround times at a
minimum of
uh by of two-thirds so if you took three
days to get a test result it goes down
to less than one if it took six days
goes down to less than two
and it's more labor-intensive um so they
would need to hire additional personnel
but cms
is funding the test at about four times
the actual test costs
to ensure technicians and ppe
requirements can be met so
we are seeing encouraging signs on that
front yes thank you
um just going back to the portland
situation what is sort of the policy
justification for federal
officers not identifying their agency
and their arrest authority when they
take a protester into custody so i've
been told by dhs that there is insignia
indicating that their law enforcement
they and the case you're referencing did
identify themselves to the individual
um being obtained but that they don't
identify themselves to crowds because it
would put them at great risk and i think
you can see that as i noted when they're
sticking their hands into boards left
out by some of the rioters
yes you know on june 16th
a little more than a month ago the white
house via the vice president
published an op-ed in the wall street
journal
the op-ed said that the media
has tried to scare the american people
about the coronavirus
it talked about low positivity rates and
declining case numbers
in half of the states um
there were 25 000 additional deaths
since that was published
does the white house still stand by that
op-ed and then just more generally
what happened here at the white house in
the administration in the last month
when the message was that this was a
problem
that was on the mend and being addressed
until now
with the exploding cases we've seen and
141 000
deaths well the white house has always
been very clear-eyed that as we reopen
we would see embers and in some cases
fires we've been very aggressive in
addressing that sent out 19 teams to go
to
emerging hot spots dr berks has been to
nine states um
she does a lot of extraordinary work on
that front so we've been clear-eyed that
as we reopened we would see
embers and sometimes fires but we're
encouraged that when you look at case
fatality for instance we're below the
european union
we're below the average of the world and
i think that that speaks to our
incredible work with therapeutics and
our incredible work with testing 46
million tests
the number two in testing in the world
is india at 13.79 million
do you still see the main problem as the
op-ed pointed out as the
media trying to scare the american
people over coronavirus
i think in many cases the media has
tried to scare the american people i
think um there's been
a deficit in reporting about the cost of
staying shut down for instance when you
have
uh the fact that the american cancer
society saying that during the pandemic
we saw an 80
drop in cancer cases being identified
there are real costs
uh to a draconian extended shutdown and
you never
heard the other side of the health
equation you never heard
that mammograms were down by 87 percent
and colonoscopies down by 90
and drug overdoses going up month after
month through the lockdown so
it was the right decision to make uh the
president saved three to four million
lives but
it's important to note the other side of
the health equation about what extended
lockdowns do to the american people
yeah the president says he wants to send
these forces
to other cities like chicago
of cities that where the federal
property isn't necessarily under attack
what are they going to do when they get
to chicago and these other cities with
higher
crime rates higher shooting rates higher
murder rates
if the president's worried about that
what are they going to do what are they
going to arrest people
well i think you're getting ahead of the
president here
he's made no announcements as to who's
going where he's very discouraged by the
violence that he's seen in chicago it's
why he sent
on a very strong letter to mayor
lightfoot offering help because she's
clearly unable to control her streets
and the governor as well unable to
control that area
when you see the fact that there were 49
officers who were injured in this
egregious video
of them being lambasted with rioters
with umbrellas shielding from view that
they were throwing projectiles and 49
officers
injured not only that the the poor
citizenry of chicago where 12 were
murdered this weekend
um 70 shot alone it's incredible what
we're seeing in chicago he's offered his
help and we encourage the mayor to take
it
and to be forthright about the situation
in her state much like
the governor of missouri was in working
with us on operation legend to protect
the people of missouri
but the leaders of these cities don't
necessarily want unmarked
police officers patrolling their streets
the way
we've seen in portland and with the
premise that they're protecting federal
property there
the leaders in these cities don't want
this sort of paramilitary police
they're offered the assistance of doj as
was done um
where you've had fbi surge in the case
of operation legend
so when you have each weekend more than
a dozen people getting shot in your city
perhaps it's time more than a dozen
killed i should say and children perhaps
it's time to say
i need the help of the federal
government because what i'm doing is
simply not working
when more people are dying on the
streets of chicago than afghanistan and
iraq it's a tragedy what if they don't
say this yes
thank you well i have a question about
new york on a similar topic
yesterday uh president trump mentioned
the spike in violent crime in new york
and said quote
if the governor is not going to do
something about it we'll do something
about it and i'm curious if you could
explain why
he's saying that the governor should do
something about it rather than the mayor
and if you could also elaborate on what
president trump would be willing to do
well he thinks the mayor and the
governor should work together to take
control of the streets of new york city
where in some places we've seen
600 percent surge in violence over last
year so he thinks they should work
together it's ultimately the power
of the mayor uh to enforce in the the
governor
to enforce the police power of their
states that power rests with them but
they can partner with the federal
government in the event they're unable
to control the violence in their cities
and that's certainly what we've seen
from mayor de blasio who seems to have
um
not a hard time criticizing police
officers but an awfully hard time
controlling the streets of new york city
actually thanks so much i have two
questions i'm not going to pull it for
today one for myself and one for a
colleague who cannot be here
social distancing governor gavin newsom
was one of the few democratic governors
to bring in the national guard and arm
them
after the riots moving in early june as
compared to seattle where they didn't on
the national guard
the guard was posted at los angeles city
hall as a show of force
and within days the violence had dwelled
um
why not just invoke the insurrection act
and have a big show of force
rather than these more secretive
operations so i'll leave that to the
president
um we don't have secretive operations
going on it's very clear what's going on
in portland it's very clear what's
happening
um in kansas city um but with with
regard to the insurrection act
look we believe that it should be
governors and mayors doing what they
have the constitutional power to do the
police power rest with them
um so it's up to this president whether
he ever decides to invoke that but
governors and mayors really need to step
it up particularly in democrat
cities where democrat streets are out of
control and then the one from my
colleague um
john gizzy at newsmax is asking what are
the president's thoughts on john kasich
supporting joe biden and his plans to
appear at the
convention john kasich um
is supporting joe biden and he plans to
attend the convention
and support the democratic conventions
so that would be a question for the
campaign but this president's quite
proud of his record in the republican
party and quite
proud to have the support of 96 of the
party more than
any predecessor in the history of the
republican party yes
thanks kaylee um you said earlier that
the president was tested multiple times
a day
we knew he was tested daily but can you
elaborate on that how many times a day
he's tested often i'm not going to read
out exactly how many times he's tested
today but sometimes it is more than one
time a day
yes uh yesterday the president said that
when he was previously doing briefings
we had a lot of people watching record
numbers watching the history of cable
television
and i was wondering if ratings are
factoring into his decision to restart
the briefing
and if he is the best person to get
accurate information about the virus out
to the public
given previous statements of briefings
like the speculation that disinfectants
inside the human body
could work as a treatment which uh
medical experts say is not the case
and claims that the virus will just
disappear well the president is the
right person to give information to the
american people he was elected by the
american people
he's been a leader on this um the fact
that we've uh
we've out produced on ventilators so
much so that we have an extraordinary
number
in our stockpile and we're giving
ventilators out to the rest of the world
that we lead
the world in testing 46 million tests
more than that
at this point the fact that he's broken
down bureaucracy to get
a vaccine into phase three clinical
trial that because of him we have room
desevere and convalescent plasma and
dexamethasone and
other therapeutics he's the right person
to give the information to the american
people
and uh boy does he get the information
to a lot of the american people during
his briefings as noted by the ratings as
he himself
pointed out yes the u.s trade
representative is planning additional
second tariffs against europe in the old
dispute about
aerospace subsidies is the president
committed to impose additional sanctions
considering that europe would answer
with additional
tariffs as well so since that's
pre-decisional i won't get ahead of on
any administration announcements on that
front
yes can i have a couple of questions the
first one is the president in last
year's tweeted about
the concerns about mail-in voting so
he's obviously concerned about the
integrity
of the u.s election and certainly
internal sabotage but why are we not
hearing from the president about the
fears about
external sabotage for example coming out
of the uk today
there's a parliamentary committee report
that says that
russia influenced the scottish
referendum there are questions about
brexit
but we've really not heard the president
put the kremlin on notice with respect
to the u.s
election will we hear from him today on
that the president put the world on
notice that our election systems must be
secure
this is under this president 2018 he
articulated the first
full cyber strategy for the united
states since 2003.
in 2019 he extended the national
emergency declaration on foreign
election interference he routinely
engages with congress on election
security
um participating 26 elections
security specific hearings um he signed
legislation 71 million dollars
and so on and so forth and that's quite
a contrast to
the obiden the obama biden
administration
who when told of meddling in 2016 did
nothing and in fact susan rice told the
white house cyber team
to stand down and quote knock it off
when they floated
um when they floated options to combat
russian cyber attacks and even obama's
cyber chief
michael daniel has confirmed the stand
down order that's been in office now
more than three years i'm asking what's
been done
now and given these fresh concerns
what are we going to hear from the
president what's been done now i just
listed off three or four things for you
and i'm happy to go through more
we can talk about the 71 million in
legislation on
election security uh we can talk about
the 15 million for election reform
activities we can talk about legislation
making more than
805 million available to states and
when it comes to mail and voting um i
would point you to the fact that there's
a wall street journal article just out
today and it talks about the dark omen
for november and the absolute
catastrophe in new york city that we are
a month into the election after the
voting
and we still don't know who the winners
are of some of those races and
governor cuomo decided that he would
pre-pay
postage for the ballots and what that
meant was that the post office didn't
put a
postage stamp noting the date uh of the
ballot so as they're collecting these
ballots
in for a month as you asked me about
this so i'm going to answer
so for a month they've been collecting
ballots with no postmark date and in
fact what they found is
19 of ballots have been rejected in
queens 28
rejected in brooklyn there are questions
about mail mass mail out voting
and i know you don't want to hear them
which is why you talk over me
but i encourage you to read the op-ed on
the china vaccine researchers yeah
you've done two questions which is more
than some of your colleagues
yes thank you kelly thank you very much
um in saint louis
i've been charged with for waving guns
at protesters the
missouri attorney general is vowing to
dismiss these charges
where does the president stand on this
yeah the president i asked him about
that this morning
and he said it is absolutely absurd what
is happening to the mccloskeys
um he noted that this is an extreme
abuse of power by the prosecutor and
know early that the prosecutor there
have been many cases brought to her
attention of violent rioters that she's
failed to charge but instead
she's charging the individuals who are
defending themselves
um from violent protesters you have 300
to 500 protesters who stormed the gates
tore down the gates and trespassed on
their property and you had patricia
mccloskey
who said that they were telling her they
were going to kill them
these protesters at the moment they were
waving their guns to protect themselves
they were going to come in here she said
they were going to burn down the house
they were going to be living in our
house
after i was dead and they were pointing
to different rooms of the house saying
that's going to be my bedroom that's
going to be my living room and i'm going
to be taking a shower in that room
so they were completely within their
right and it's an egregious abuse of
power on the part of the mccloskeys
um turning to a different note i just
wanted to highlight some some great work
being done by senior advisor
ivanka trump there are nearly 40 million
boxes that have been put together by the
farmers to family food box program a
great partnership to help
families in need in this country and
yesterday you had
ivanka trump visiting the dc dream
center and personally distributing a
number of food boxes
uh the distribution resulted in 1 000
boxes delivered to the dc
community um and we thank ivanka for the
great work that she has done there
and finally i just wanted to note
something on kovid um
dr burks is an extraordinary
uh doctor who served this country
dedicated
her time to serving our country as an
army colonel
she served as an ambassador to pepfar
where she spent her life fighting aids
and hiv abroad and it is appalling the
attack that i saw
on her in the new york times based on no
facts and dr burks for weeks has been
sending out
this data to governors 400 pages of data
to our governors
so that they have the best information
to make the best decisions for their
people in their respective states
i've not seen anyone pouring over data
the way dr burks has and the attack on
her
was frankly appalling and egregious and
the new york times
should be very ashamed of themselves
you